Jupiter could be considered an independent
solar system, only in miniature form.
The gas giant has the same basic ingredients
as the sun and is surrounded by dozens of
geologically diverse moons.
Out of the 79 confirmed surrounding Jupiter,
four ancient moons have astronomers really
excited because they offer up some of the
most distinctive geology in the solar system,
including clues of deep, subsurface oceans
that could be home to life.
The Galilean moons are named after Galileo
Galilei, who first observed them in 1610.
Io, Jupiter’s closest Galilean moon, is
unusual because its composition is closer
in comparison to the terrestrial planets than
the icy bodies that surround it.
Io is also the most volcanically active body
known in the solar system
with over 400 active volcanoes.
This is due to the internal heating produced
by the pulling and stretching effect of Jupiter's
gravity and smaller neighboring moons on Io
as it orbits Jupiter.
That same tug-of-war heating effect is the
reason why some astronomers believe that Jupiter’s
second Galilean moon is home to a deep subsurface
ocean up to twice the volume of Earth's oceans.
Unlike Io, Europa has an icy surface, but
below it, astronomers think there may be a
salty ocean that could harbor life-bearing
chemistry, including organic molecules.
When Europa swings by Jupiter on an elliptical
orbit, gravitational tidal forces stretch
and flex the sides of the moon,
creating internal friction that essentially heats the moon from the inside out.
Using its Europa Clipper spacecraft in the
2020s, NASA plans to get a closer look at
the moon in order to confirm the existence
of a potential ocean.
Europa’s neighbor, Ganymede, is also believed
to have an ocean hidden under its thick icy shell.
The moon’s magnetic field may be affected
by an electrically conducting layer from within,
which hints at the existence of a liquid saltwater
ocean.
But Ganymede’s distance from Jupiter means
there’s a weaker tidal force at play, so
it’s less likely that liquid water is present.
The moon is the only one in the solar system
known to have a magnetosphere, protecting
its surface from harmful radiation and solar
wind.
As Jupiter’s largest moon, Ganymede would
be considered a planet
if it were orbiting the Sun.
Out of all four Galilean moons, Callisto is
the farthest from Jupiter.
The moon is purported to be one of the most
heavily cratered objects in the solar system.
With some impact basins expanding to about
2,600 kilometers across, these craters could
teach us a lot about the formation of our
early solar system, as astronomers believe
its surface hasn’t changed in over four
billion years.
Unmanned spacecraft have been conducting flybys
of the Galilean moons for decades and findings
from these missions suggest an even greater
presence of water.
Along with NASA’s Europa Clipper, the European
Space Agency’s JUpiter ICy moons Explorer
aka JUICE will gain a deeper understanding
of the moons’ mysterious properties.
But getting to these moons will be no small
feat since the craft will need to slingshot
around the Sun and then travel about 800 million
kilometers before being caught by Jupiter’s
massive gravitational pull.
If the spacecraft can survive this arduous
journey and manage to generate enough energy
to travel between the moons, astronomers will
gain an unparalleled glimpse into what lies
beneath their surfaces, which could even result
in the discovery of the
first forms of life beyond Earth.
Space Crafts takes you through the depths
of the cosmos, explaining bizarre astronomical
phenomena and crazy plans for future exploration.
In this episode, we explain how an advanced
civilization could harness
the total energy of a star.
Thanks for watching Seeker!
Don’t forget to subscribe.